il y a de quoi faire ce matin au gymnase
Alain Colas de Montigny-le-Bretonneux
chaque année la Ville propose des
animations pour les parents et les
enfants ce matin la journée commence
avec l'atelier bouge bricole et joue en
famille c'est un lieu qui permet aussi
l'association voilà le j'apprends à
vivre ensemble déjà tout petit je me
prépare des fois même à l'entrée à
l'école donc en septembre et j'apprends
à socialiser les ateliers présents pour
ce dispositif ont été pensés par des
références familles de la ville on y
retrouve un atelier motricité activité
manuelle et jeux d'imitation des
activités variées pour les enfants ça
travaille la motricité l'éveil la vie en
communauté aussi pour les enfants donc
c'est très bien donc et puis les parents
ça permet aussi de proposer aussi
d'autres activités à leurs enfants donc
c'est complémentaires avec ce qu'on peut
faire d'habitude tout le long de l'année
pour qu'elle puisse bien s'amuser avec
le petit parcours de motricité c'est
vrai qu'on n'a pas pas forcément ça à la
maison ça lui permet de faire des
activités et de se défouler on adore ça
elle est elle adore elle a beaucoup de
patience elle aime bien découper elle
aime bien elle aime bien faire des
activités donc du coup ils nous aussi
j'aime ça on peut faire ensemble je
l'aide le reste de la journée les
familles ont aussi accès aux jeux en
extérieur structure gonflable bac à
sable ou encore toboggan les parents
aussi ils trouvent leur compte
c'est plutôt cool pour le parrain parce
qu'en fait les enfants sont libres de
jouer on ne doit pas trop s'occuper de
tous les temps c'est sécurisé après ça
nous permet aussi de voir des amis en
même temps les enfants jouaient ensemble
nous on peut passer un peu des moments
avec les nos amis l'événement est
gratuit est accessible pour les inhy
montants sous présentation d'une pièce
d'identité d'un justificatif de domicile
ou d'un livret de famille l'été en sable
se tiendra jusqu'au 6 août